A very important category of copyrighted
works consists of works of visual art,
or as the statute puts it, "pictorial,
graphical, and sculptural works."
Most of the things that
fall into this zone
are obvious-- paintings,
posters, statues, and so forth.
However, two dimensions
of the protection
extended to pictorial,
graphic and sculptural works
are not obvious and are important.
The first is that,
nowadays, copyright law
is often used by companies
to shield the logos that they
apply to consumer products.
Here's an example.
The Omega watch company
has obtained a US Copyright
on the design shown on your screen,
which it calls the Omega globe design.
From lecture number
one, you should remember
how and why a Swiss company
can get a US copyright.
Omega engraves a version of this
logo on the underside of its watches,
which are typically
manufactured in Switzerland
but sold all over the world.
Typically, Omega sells its watches
for lower prices in poor countries
than it does in more wealthy countries.
Some years ago, Costco,
an American discounter,
using an intermediary,
purchased some of the watches
that Omega had sold cheaply
outside the United States,
imported them into the United
States, and began selling them
in Costco's US stores for prices
lower than the prices charged
by Omega's authorized US dealers.
Omega, dismayed,
brought suit, contending
that this so-called parallel
importation violated Omega's copyright
in the logo, not its trademark or
patent rights, but its copyright.
The legal rule underlying
this lawsuit and its outcome
we'll consider when we discuss the
rights of distribution and importation
in lecture number eight.
For now, I just want to emphasize
the expansive reach of the subject
matter of copyright and
how companies like Omega
try to use that expansive
coverage to engage
in international geographic
price discrimination
when making their products
available in different countries.
The second non-obvious
dimension of this category
involves what is sometimes called
applied art or industrial design.
These typically consist of
three dimensional objects
that are intended to be
both useful and attractive.
Objects of this sort permeate
modern consumer culture.
Just look around the room or space
where you are located right now.
Most likely, you'll notice many objects
that fit this general definition.
Possibilities include an unusual
lamp, a container of bottled water,
a distinctive coffee mug, the shape
of a laptop computer or a tablet,
your eyeglasses if you wear them,
a decorative doorknob or window
fixture, a decorative table
or chair, and so forth.
Each of these things combines
in some way art and function.
In the United States, three
different systems of law
are potentially available to the
creators of new objects of this sort--
copyright law, design patent
law, and the protection
that trademark law extends
to so-called trade dress.
Some innovations qualify under
more than one of these systems,
but others fail to qualify under any.
It all depends on the shape and
history of the particular object,
and sometimes on the whims of
the tribunal evaluating it.
If you're curious about the potential
reach of design patent law or trademark
law, feel free to follow those
branches of the map on your own
using the interactive version
you can get through my website.
I'll concentrate here,
for obvious reasons,
on the possibility of copyright
protection for such objects.
In the late 19th century, it was
clear that copyright law did not
extend to works of applied
art or industrial design.
After 1870, three
dimensional forms of fine art
were shielded, but not the
kind of consumer products
to which I directed your
attention a minute ago.
Then gradually, through a series
of steps itemized on your map,
Congress, the Copyright
Office, and finally the courts
liberalized the relevant rules.
Today, the governing general
principle is that copyright protection
is available to
so-called useful articles
if and only if the aesthetic
and functional features of those
articles are separable.
The first step in
applying this principle
is to determine whether a
particular object qualifies as a,
quote, "useful" article.
The reason why this is so important
is that if an object does not
constitute a useful article, the
ordinary lenient rules of copyright law
apply, whereas if it does
constitute a useful article,
it has to pass more stringent tests.
So what does the technical
term "useful article" mean?
The statute defines it as follows.
"A useful article is an article having
an intrinsic utilitarian function that
is not merely to portray the
appearance of the article
or to convey information."
Some applications of this
definition will be straightforward.
For example, Rodin's sculpture does
not constitute a useful article
because its function
is to depict itself,
to depict, in other words, a thinker.
By contrast, a lamp, no
matter how beautiful,
is a useful article because it has
a function other than looking good,
namely, illuminating a room.
In other instances, however, application
of this definition is much trickier.
If a particular object is deemed
to fall into this special category,
then its creator gets
copyright protection,
to repeat, only if its aesthetic and
functional dimensions are separable.
How might they be separable?
There are two options.
The first, which arises rarely,
is that the two dimensions
might be physically separable.
For example, as the treatise
writer Melville Nimmer suggests,
the stylized Jaguar shape that is
attached to the hood of a Jaguar
automobile enjoys copyright protection
because it could be physically removed
from the car without impairing
its utilitarian function.
Likewise, the utilitarian
components of the car
could be removed from the Jaguar without
impairing its aesthetic features.
With respect to most useful articles,
however, physical separability
of this sort is not feasible.
The creators of such objects may
still obtain copyright protection,
but only if they can demonstrate that
the aesthetic and utilitarian features
are, quote, "conceptually separable."
What does that mean?
The conceptual separability inquiry
is the most intriguing and least
satisfying aspect of this doctrine.
US courts, as you can see from the map,
have developed five distinct families
of interpretations of this term.
The first of the five approaches asks
whether the form of the object at issue
is dictated by its function.
If so, conceptual
separability does not exist.
This variant was emphasized
by the majority of the judges
in the influential 1985
Barnhart case, which
involved these two sets of mannequins,
which were copied by a competitor
without permission.
The majority of the judges
in that case contended
that the shape of the
mannequins was, quote,
"required by their function,"
namely displaying clothes in stores,
and consequently that their
utilitarianism and aesthetic features
were inextricably combined.
The second of the five approaches asks
which aspect of the object in question
is primary.
So for example, the court in
the Kieselstein-Cord case,
another influential
Second Circuit opinion,
concluded that the, quote, "ornamental
aspect" of these belt buckles
was primary and their utilitarian
function, namely holding pants up,
was subsidiary, and thus that
they enjoyed copyright protection.
The third approach was made famous
by Judge Newman's dissenting opinion
in the Barnhart case,
which I mentioned earlier.
It's commonly known as the,
quote, "temporal displacement,"
closed quote, test.
The key question under this approach
is whether the article stimulates
in the mind of the
beholder a concept that
is separate from the concept
evoked by its utilitarian function.
If so, there's conceptual separability.
If not, not.
The phrase "temporal displacement"
comes from Newman's contention
that the two concepts,
utilitarian and non-utilitarian,
must occur to the beholder not
simultaneously but separated in time.
Newman's test is
intriguing and continues
to attract the interest of scholars,
but so far, few judicial adherents.
The fourth approach asks whether the
article at issue can stand on its own
as a work of art.
If so, it enjoys protection.
There are at least two different
ways of elaborating this approach.
Paul Goldstein suggests that we ask
whether the article could constitute
a work of art, quote, "traditionally
conceived," which is related,
he argues, to whether
the article would be
equally useful without
its aesthetic feature.
Goldstein's reference to
art traditionally conceived
naturally draws us back
into the debate we discussed
in the first lecture concerning
the best way of defining art.
For the reasons we
reviewed there, resolving
that question would be difficult,
although perhaps unavoidable.
By contrast, Goldstein's
fellow treatise writer Nimmer
points to a more
empirical interpretation,
asking whether a significant
number of copies of the article
would be purchased if it
had no utilitarian use.
This approach was adopted
by the Court of Appeals
for the Fifth Circuit
in the Galiano case,
which involved uniforms for employees
of the Harrah's gambling casino.
The fifth and last of
the approaches focuses
on the intent of the creator of the
article, the individual designer who
determined its final shape.
This approach was adopted
by the Court of Appeals
for the Second Circuit
in the Brandir case,
which involved the
following interesting facts.
David Levine was playing
around with some wires,
making miniature sculptures in his home.
He twisted one wire into the
shape of a bicycle and another
into the shape of a ribbon,
and then placed both along,
with some other designs,
on his mantelpiece.
A friend of his pointed
out that the ribbon shape
could serve as a useful rack
for the miniature bicycle.
Inspired, Levine worked with
a friend to refine the design
and eventually began manufacturing
and selling commercial versions
under the company name
Brandir International.
This product is depicted on this slide.
Here's a blow up of the photo
of the rack and another image
showing how bicycles
can be locked to it.
The rack proved popular and a
competitor, Cascade Pacific Lumber,
began producing knockoffs.
Brandir brought a copyright
infringement suit against Cascade.
The outcome of the case hinged
on whether the ribbon rack
satisfies the conceptual
separability test.
Relying on a 1983 article by
the scholar Robert Denicola,
the Court of Appeals for the Second
Circuit announced the following test.
If design elements reflect a
merger of aesthetic and functional
considerations, the artistic aspects
of a work cannot be said to be
conceptually separable from
the utilitarian elements.
Conversely, where design
elements can be identified
as reflecting the designer's artistic
judgment exercised independently
of functional influences,
conceptual separability exists.
Applying this approach, the
court ruled against Brandir,
emphasizing several ways in
which Levine had modified
the shape of the original abstract
sculpture in order to make it durable
and to accommodate as many
bicycles and mopeds as possible.
Because the shape of the
product did not reflect, quote,
"artistic expression uninhibited
by functional considerations,"
closed quote, it could
be copied with impunity.
As one might expect, the
net result of the decision
is that other companies
now manufacture and sell
competing versions of the ribbon rack.
The approach exemplified
by Brandir now appears
to be gaining in
popularity among courts.
Whether that trend will
continue remains to be seen.
If it does, one can expect
designers of industrial products
in the future to include in their
designs features unconstrained
by functional considerations and,
with the support of their employers,
to document their indulgence
of their artistic impulses.
There remains one more type of
three dimensional object that
now enjoys copyright
protection, architecture.
Inclusion of architecture in
the list was a long time coming
and its implications are
still not entirely clear.
Here's a bit of background.
The original 1886 version
of the Berne Convention
included architectural
plans in the set of things
that member countries
were obliged to protect,
but not architectural works per se.
Application of this principle would
mean that if you copied the drawings
that an architect had prepared to
guide the construction of a building,
you would be liable for
infringement, but not
if you were able to construct an
identical building without use
of those plans.
In 1890, the Belgian
scholar Jules de Borchgrave
published an article criticizing
this state of affairs
and arguing that works of architecture
deserve protection identical to that
employed by other works of art,
such as painting and music.
Borchgrave's argument slowly took
root in European copyright systems,
first in Belgium, then in France.
For a while, some countries,
England and Germany,
resisted adoption of his
proposal on the grounds
that it could prevent replication of
ordinary, non-innovative buildings,
and thus would retard development.
But, when reassured that the
proposal would only apply to,
quote, "original artistic work,"
closed quote, they acquiesced.
A key step in this
campaign was the addition
of architectural works to Article
2(1) of the 1908 version of the Berne
Convention.
As you know, the United States
did not join the Berne Convention
until 80 years later.
Until it did so, copyright protection
for architecture in this country
was skimpy.
Architectural plans were shielded,
as they were in most countries,
and a few cases took the position that
an architect whose plans were copied
without his permission could prevent
construction of the building using
those plans, but the
buildings themselves
were treated as useful articles, just
like the types of industrial design
we considered a minute ago.
As such, they were subject to
the conceptual separability test.
Only if the aesthetic
components of a building
were separable from its
utilitarian features
did they enjoy protection
against non-permissive copying.
Rarely was this true.
When the United States did
finally join the Berne Convention,
Congress considered whether formally
to extend copyright protection
to architectural works.
It initially decided
not to do so, persuaded
that the protections available
for useful articles were adequate,
but it commissioned a report
from the Copyright Office
which, when it was issued,
urged that the law be modified.
And finally, Congress adopted
the Architectural Works Copyright
Protection Act, which
became effective in 1990.
The key provisions of the new
statute are set forth on your screen.
Notice that it's limited to
architectural works, which
are defined as the design of a building.
Courts in the United States
have construed "building"
to be limited to
freestanding structures.
The most important implication
of this new statute
is that in the United States,
architectural works no longer
have to run the gauntlet of the
conceptual separability test.
To be sure, like all
types of copyrighted work,
a piece of architecture must be original
to be protectable, but as we've seen,
the standard for originality is soft.
Here's an example of a building
design that would clearly pass muster.
In 1989, the Polish born
architect Daniel Libeskind
won a competition to design
the Jewish Museum in Berlin.
Here's a photograph of the building
taken from directly above it,
and a second aerial photograph
taken from a slight angle.
As you see, the shape of the building
is unusual, a complex zigzag.
Here's how Libeskind himself
explained the structure.
His architectural partner
and wife, Nina Libeskind,
emphasized the theme mentioned at
the end of the second paragraph
on your screen, likening the
shape of the building to a, quote,
"broken star of David."
In the late 1990s, the Australian
architect Howard Raggatt
was commissioned to design the new
National Museum of Australia, which
was to be located on this peninsula
in the center of Canberra.
Raggatt's much celebrated design
is shown in these aerial photos.
Until the Australian
museum had been finished,
no one apparently
noticed the resemblance
between its central building
and the Jewish Museum in Berlin,
but once the connection was suggested,
the parallelism becomes unmistakable.
This case never resulted in litigation.
Had it done so, it
most likely would have
resulted in liability for
Raggatt and the Australian firm.
Since 1968, Australian copyright law
has extended to, among other things,
quote, "a building or
model of a building,
whether the building or model
is of artistic quality or not."
Certainly, if this standard
were construed in the same way
the current US standard is
construed, Libeskind's design
would qualify for protection,
and the Australian museum
resembles it sufficiently to
satisfy the legal standard
of substantial similarity.
The fact that the case, nevertheless,
was not litigated bears emphasis.
Why not?
We can't be sure, but probably
two factors were at work.
First, copyright litigation is
very time consuming and expensive.
As a result, only a tiny percentage
of potentially actionable cases
ever end up in court.
Second, architects, at
least high end architects,
seem especially loath to rely on
copyright to protect their work.
Peer pressure and public
condemnation, they seem to think,
are more effective mechanisms
for discouraging knockoffs.
Indeed, such extra legal
sanctions were deployed
in this particular controversy.
The Libeskinds publicly
expressed outrage
and the press, both in Germany
and in Australia, condemned
what one paper called, quote,
"architectural kleptomania."
The director of the Australian
museum, who apparently had not
known of the relationship
between the two buildings,
expressed misgivings,
publicly acknowledging
that, quote, "had we
known, we might well
have asked for that particular reference
not to be included," closed quote.
Interestingly, however, Raggatt himself
seems to have had no such reservations.
The overall design of
the Australian museum
is clearly postmodern in character,
alluding to many other structures.
Raggatt readily admitted to having
been inspired by the Jewish Museum
and does not seem to resist the
inference drawn by many observers
that he intended to analogize
the treatment of Aborigines
in Australia to the treatment
of the Jews in the Holocaust.
As one might imagine,
that suggestion remains
highly controversial in Australia.
The more general point
latent in this example
is that there is not complete
consensus, even among architects,
concerning the definition
and significance of copying.
What to one person constitutes
plagiarism or theft
may to another seem
quotation or allusion.
The law, as we've seen,
now sides with the former.
Whether it should is
one of the questions
I hope you'll be in a
position soon to answer.
This concludes lecture number three.
Next week we'll return
to copyright theory,
examining in some detail
the utilitarian approach.
The week after that, we'll return
to the law and discuss authorship.